Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my New Avengers Wandavision
video recently it was reported that we
have a big surprise joining the series
from a whole other comic book universe
so we'll break it down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a whole
bunch of x-men Easter eggs in this too
and because of everything that's going
on this week also includes some links in
the description for resources and how to
help people so just going down the list
starting with number 5 if you didn't see
the news recently it was reported that
Quicksilver himself was joining
Wandavision obviously everyone kind of
expected some sort of Quicksilver Easter
Egg but here's the thing it's not the
Quicksilver you expected from the comic
book universe you expected supposedly
it's Evan Peters
who's landed a role on Wandavision and
it was late last year and then he filmed
his scenes shortly after in secret
not quite the version of Quicksilver you
were expecting bet you didn't see that
coming but there's a lot of theories
about who he's playing and whether or
not it's his version of Quicksilver from
the Fox x-men movies but there was a
very big Quicksilver Easter egg scene
that we heard about last year that they
filmed and might have something to do
with this Evan Peters casting reveal so
if you didn't know what's going on
earlier this year they've already
finished filming the Wandavision
episodes the Disney CEO the new CEO
confirmed that they would be airing all
the Disney Plus series that they've
filmed before the end of the year that
includes Wandavision that includes the
Falcon and Winter Soldier episodes the
mandalorian season 2 episodes they might
be delayed by a couple weeks but they're
still going to get that stuff out
apparently they even finished filming
Wandavision before they finished Falcon
and Winter Soldier so all that stuff is
in the can they're doing special effects
and stuff like that right now but while
they were filming some of the scenes
leaked out and they detailed a scene
from an episode featuring Scarlet Witch
envisions twins the children that you
see during the trailer talking about a
guest staying in their home referring to
them as their uncle so automatically
because vision doesn't have any
relatives
everyone just immediately thought of
scarlet witch's brother Quicksilver and
because the series is all about
alternate realities scarlet witch's
chaos magic
the multiverse because we're crossing
over with doctor strange 2 the multiverse
of madness in everything comic books
Scarlet Witch from the comics it just
seemed like they were using her
reality-warping powers and magic to
create an alternate reality for herself
where everyone she loved and her
families were still alive both vision in
her brother like somehow because of all
these fakes sitcom realities she was
creating the life for herself that she
always wanted to have but never had the
chance to because all of her family died
between Avengers age of Ultron with
Quicksilver and then Avengers infinity
war with vision remember all the
questions after avengers endgame how
come they didn't bring vision back if
surety is so smart how can they just
didn't recreate him or repair him even
if it was an alternate version of him
that's all because of what they're doing
with the character on the Wanda vision
series in the multiverse story so if
Evan Peters is really playing a version
of his Quicksilver from the Fox x-men
movies it would be huge not only would
it go a long way to explaining how
Marvel intends on treating all the
pre-existing Fox x-men movie characters
in Canon in the MCU it just becomes a
cool template for more x-men crossovers
in the future from other actors like
Michael Fassbender's magneto James
McAvoy as Professor X and anyone else
from the Fox x-men movies that wants to
come into the MCU movies for a cameo and
if we're talking about versions of
Quicksilver here the Evan Peters
Quicksilver got way more screen time
across his movies than the MCU
Quicksilver did it was probably one of
the few redeeming qualities of x-men
apocalypse even if they mostly kept
using the characters same speed gag in
each of his scenes I would say Days of
Future past Quicksilver is probably the
best version of him in that universe
just because he was so important to that
story and he was more of a gag in later
x-men movies the way they visualized his
speed was also very different too but
you have to remember that they were sort
of debuting his Quicksilver around the
same time that Joss Whedon's Quicksilver
and Avengers age of Ultron was debuting
so we think the Marvel and Fox people
just wanted to tiptoe around each other
so they wanted to make sure that they
differentiated the way they portrayed
the character in both of their movies to
be very different you guys can let me
know which quickserver you prefer do you
like the way they used Quicksilver in
the Fox movies more or do you like the
MCU version of Quicksilver more they
also have very different backstories
I'll talk about that in a second too
because remember this is all about the
multiverse alternate realities
that's the easiest way to explain around
any continuity errors this is a really
cool thing about bringing in morefox
x-men Easter eggs as we've never seen
Quicksilver and Scarlet witch's MCU
parents before they only talk about
their deaths at the hands of stark tech
weaponry during Avengers age of Ultron
like they had this horrific past their
parents were killed in an attack
preceding the events of Baron von
strucker's experiments and it just
happened to be stark tech weaponry that
the people attacking them are using so
then after their parents died they sort
of volunteer themselves with Baron von
strucker's program he experiments on
them with the Infinity stone and Loki's
scepter the mine stone and that's how
they get their powers Quicksilver in the
Fox movies has a more traditional
backstory magneto just had a
relationship with his mother he was born
but magneto had moved on to other
grander plans so he didn't know that he
had these children because Quicksilver
had a sister who was arguably supposed
to be their version of Scarlet Witch but
she was so young during Days of Future
past and they didn't bring the character
back during the other movies so it's
kind of hard to tell what was going to
happen with her then they kind of went
off the rails with the continuity when
they got to x-men apocalypse and Dark
Phoenix like he had this other family
with other children this other daughter
that wound up dying is she a version of
Scarlet Witch in the Fox movies it's
hard to say that's why it's so important
that you use the multiverse to explain
things entire these Easter eggs together
but there's also a lot of people that
read this news about Evan Peters being
cast for Wandavision who believe that
he's not playing his Quicksilver but
instead they brought him on board the
series in a more American Horror Story
style twist and he's going to be playing
one of the villains if you've never
watched American Horror Story Evan
Peters has been in many different
versions of that show because it's kind
of an anthology series he's played very
dark twisted sometimes evil characters
so it's not unheard of for him to play
villains in a TV show like this because
technically even though it's a big event
series Wandavision is still kind of a
TV series and since we're talking about
doing core Scarlet Witch stories from
the comics and Wandavision is supposed
to crossover with Doctor Strange 2 the
multiverse of madness that might mean
he's playing one of the fear Lords the
main villain of Doctor Strange 2 is
supposedly going to be the nightmare
character at least right now unless they
made some change because of the virus
delays Sam Raimi is still directing the
movie he and Kevin Feige could wind up
swapping some of the villain mechanics
because originally went
scott derrickson was directing doctor
strange 2 he had talked about using
nightmare as the villain so it's always
possible that they wind up changing that
to a different character so connecting
this back to Wanda vision if Evan Peters
is also playing one of the fear Lords a
lot of people are hoping that he might
be playing an MCU version of Mephisto
but here's the thing about that as cool
as it would be to see him show up as
Mephisto it would still be a cool
Quicksilver Easter egg just in the shear
casting and him showing up even if it's
not meant to be a literal Easter egg in
Mephisto and Scarlet Witch have deep
history through her children in the
comics I don't know if they would
actually introduce a character as big as
Mephisto on a Disney Plus series before
he shows up in the movies there's still
a lot of people that want Mephisto to be
the main villain of Doctor Strange 2
he's obviously a solid pick for any big
Marvel movie just because he's such a
cool character but here's the way that
Paul Bettany sort of describes the story
of Wandavision across the six episodes
of season one he says they start out in
the first half with that weird alternate
reality fake sitcom that she's living in
with their twins the reality that she
creates for herself with her powers and
other big characters help which I'll
explain in a second she's probably not
the only person who's responsible for
all these weird sitcom realities then
Paul Bettany says the second half of the
series plays more like a traditional
Avengers movie with all the big crazy
action scenes the heavy plot in the big
wizard battles so the other character
that I just mentioned that might be
messing with Scarlet Witch during the
series might wind up being Agatha
Harkness
played by Kathryn Hahn she could also
wind up being one of the villains of the
series but here's the thing about her
character she's been really coy about
who she's playing and they say that
they're staying true to a lot of scarlet
witch's comic book backstory Agatha
Harkness is just the top pick for who
she might be because she's one of the
major Scarlet Witch specific villains
and allies at times she's both fought
and helped Scarlet Witch at different
times with her magic she's a very
powerful magic user just like Doctor
Strange
so Agatha Harkness could also have
something to do with Scarlet Witch
winding up in this weird alternate
sitcom reality where vision is alive
again and they're living through the
different errors of the TV sitcoms
raising their family and if it really is
true that Evan Peters winds up playing a
villain on the series and we're trying
to tie this to Doctor Strange 2 he would
most likely be someone that just tried
to take advantage of scarlet witch's
weakened mental state in her vast cosmic
powers
threaten reality then be a good intro
for Doctor Strange to get involved
because that's his whole job protecting
the main MCU reality from extra
dimensional threats like Dormammu in the
fear Lords one of my favorite lines from
Avengers infinity war between Iron Man
and Doctor Strange what is it that you
do party tricks
I protect your reality douchebag right
now the Disney Plus people said that
Falcon and Winter Soldier is still
supposed to premiere in the fall so
that's sometime around September just
based on the schedule that they've
already announced so if you're really
bummed out that everything's been
delayed because of the virus there is a
lot of really cool stuff that's dropping
the second half of the year but of
course I'll do videos and Easter eggs
for everything but leave all your
requests and big questions in the
comments below
everyone click here for my breakdown of
the other big Wandavision trailer the
Loki trailer in the Falcon and Winter
Soldier trailer and click here for my
breakdown of that new Marvel Eternals
first look teaser thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!